many across the rich world are feeling
the pinch and it's hitting hardest in
its poorest regions it's almost like
we're not meant to have those
opportunities in countries like Britain
and America Regional inequality is
already ingrained now Rising prices are
making it much worse in much of the
world now Divergence is a fundamental
fact although globalization benefited
many in well-off countries large areas
have been left in the Lurch for decades
our political classes have no idea about
the scale of the problem and it's not
just those in declining places who stand
to lose it costs the country a fortune
every single year people Revolt in The
Ballot Box and that starts to become
extremely dangerous as the cost of
living crisis bites how can Left Behind
areas be made richer and just how big is
the challenge putting in place the
necessary investment is the work of
decades
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Middlesbrough the northeast of England
local venue disgraceland is hosting a
show by one of the Region's
up-and-coming musicians shark
s cause I inject the truth inside my
body like a science game
but this is about more than just music
Shaq is hoping to change perceptions of
an area that has been culturally
underrepresented for decades
Make Some Noise if you're having a good
time
[Applause]
I do this for myself but more than
anything I'd love to to change the
perspective on on the area Middle School
is a really important place because it
represents working-class people Shaq's
Hometown is a reluctant poster child for
regional inequality in Britain
the northeast of England has some of the
highest poverty rates in the country
in my life I've seen a lot of Injustice
grown up here drugs and crime is
prevalent
you can get yourself in a lot of bother
and you know there's people really
struggling around here
very different picture
in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries Middlesbrough was a Boom Town
for steel making and shipping but in the
last few decades all that's changed and
the steel Works have been demolished all
shut down all shut down
once a Bowman steel challenge
the northeast of this country is
certainly one of those regions that
suffered very badly a lot of heavy
industry shipping if you go up to
tyneside when those Industries left
those places were very very badly hit
and they never really recovered
what I was told is you're not going to
become wealthy in Middlesbrough unless
you're a drug dealer or work offshore
Middlesbrough is part of
a problem that is particularly extensive
in Britain one often oversimplified as a
north-south divide
half the country today in the UK is
poorer than the poorest U.S states of
Mississippi and West Virginia and has a
quality of life which is about the same
as Tennessee or Alabama
at the same time half the country in the
UK today has Prosperity standards of
living which are about the same as
Australia Austria Sweden
Canada
[Music]
this dark divide is bad news for the
country's economy and politics and
Britain is far from the only country
suffering in the rich world where income
gaps between wealthy and poor regions
have been on the rise for years
countries which tend to be very
centralized and top down in terms of
governance what we see is that only
certain parts of the country seem to
really enjoy the benefits of prosperity
and they tend to leave other parts of
the country behind so how can countries
with unhealthy Regional divides fix them
well a good place to start is addressing
the tendency towards over centralization
Britain's system of government sees the
capital give money to Regional cities
and tell them how to spend it this
presumption that the government knows
best has seen London pull away from the
regions deepening the economic divide
control oh the kids are talking about
consequences one person who knows the
impact of a london-centric approach
better than most is Andy Preston his
family has lived in the Northeast for
four generations and in 2019 he was
elected mayor of Middlesbrough back in
2002 the government created a small
number of of City Mayors mayors that
would sit above a town or city a Borough
in other words the role of Mayor is
really visible now in politics
visibility equals accountability and
that's great for the residents they hold
you to account but it's only a step we
need to go much further
to really make a difference Andy says
local Mayors need more power to go with
their profile
how can you have somebody sat down in
Westminster deciding what bus route
should come in it's completely insane
it's undemocratic we have lots of
restrictions we need more autonomy more
Devolution more power and crucially more
money
between the camps of Britain you know
definitely not happening
power without money can't do much listen
we've got a crisis we've got a crisis in
suicide rates we've got a crisis in
addiction levels with a crisis in crime
Mayors and councils need to be able to
deal with this but so they need more
power but they need a lot of new money
foreign
has announced a plan to move the
treasury from London to the nearby town
of Darlington
but policies like this can seem like
token gestures when making poor areas
genuinely better off should arguably be
everyone's concern
if you live in Surrey or Southampton or
Stockport you care about middlesbrough's
crime rate and our underachievement at
schools you care because it costs the
country a fortune every single year the
gap between rich and poor is of massive
consequence to your wallet
the countries trying to make poor
regions wealthier giving these areas
more executive powers and resources is a
crucial first step
but it isn't always a slam dunk
if a region is given more power and it
has bad policies or policies that don't
work it can go into a downward spiral
even faster than it would otherwise
avoiding this Pitfall can be tricky but
one European city offers a valuable
lesson from a seismic moment in history
[Music]
the Breakthrough came last night as the
first concrete block was removed by East
German Workers in 1989 when the Berlin
Wall came down Leipzig was a poor City
part of communist East Germany
throughout the 90s it was blighted by
Rising unemployment and poor Public
Services of Leipzig there are vacancies
for more than 900 tram and bus drivers
foreign
but now Leipzig has turned a corner and
for those like Michael Weichert who
remember the old days it's been a
dramatic period of change
in
versus
Michael used to run a restaurant when
the Wall came down
he witnessed firsthand the
transformation of the city's hospitality
industry
[Music]
and its cultural Reawakening
[Music]
the key to changing the city's fortunes
has been sustained investment over time
particularly in local infrastructure
[Music]
such as Transport Systems
this is
foreign
[Music]
Germany
took on Regional development as a kind
of national priority when the two halves
of Germany were reunited
the unification of East and West Germany
is a very good example of how you need
to make serious scale and long-term
investment decisions if you really are
going to reduce inequalities between
areas
Germany has put around 2 trillion
dollars into making reunification work
and Leipzig has managed to slash its
unemployment rate from over 20 to under
5 in two decades
[Music]
but while it and other East German
cities might be on the up there's still
a 26 wage gap between East and West
Germany
not even Germany's economy could sustain
the level of investment needed to revive
every poor area of the country
[Music]
Germany has decided that only large
cities can be made economically dynamic
in England it's been decided that even
quite small towns can become sort of
economic powerhouses I think Germany is
probably more correct
deciding which areas to try to
rejuvenate demands making tough and
sometimes unpopular choices
but if some areas are left to fail it's
important people aren't too
parts of countries do simply fail the
important thing I think is that entire
regions must not decline there's got to
be areas within those regions which are
economically Dynamic where you know
people from a failing Village or a
failing small town
can can move to and become productive
[Music]
one way to increase productivity in
declining regions is to rethink the
approach to education
the Pittsburgh Steelers came away with
their seventh AFC Championship the
Pittsburgh Steelers are famous for wins
on the field
and off the field the city has a game
plan for Success too
Reinventing itself as roboburg by
rewiring its universities for the future
so basically the first thing is you can
go back here this is called the circuit
breaker at Carnegie Mellon University
Ava Miller belongs to girls of Steel a
robotics training program
it's part of a blueprint to make
Pittsburgh a flourishing hub for this
technology if you're into robotics it's
one of the things that can most help the
world it's something that anyone could
benefit from
in recent times Pittsburgh's
universities have focused on
specializing in robotics and AI with the
aim of creating a pool of graduates like
Ava skilled in these sectors Pittsburgh
is an exciting place to grow up a lot of
my friends grandparents worked in the
steel industry and it was a lot dirtier
and it wasn't as Innovative as it is now
Pittsburgh steel capital of the world
stands as a symbol of the power
generated along the Monongahela
Pittsburgh is another city which built
its fortunes on the steel industry only
to see them reversed with the collapse
of heavy industry in many parts of the
rich world
but today the growing pool of Robotics
graduates are helping Pittsburgh to
create a new cluster economy with over
100 robotics companies the city is
beginning to Boom again
over the last 30 years unemployment in
Pittsburgh has fallen from eight percent
to under 5 percent
the partnership between the cities
universities and businesses now offers
plentiful job opportunities to graduates
giving them good reason to stay put
we produce more students than we
actually have jobs for and so it's
created this ready-made work pool for
Innovative companies to expand and
create the ecosystem that we have
but creating a pool of Highly skilled
graduates doesn't always mean they stay
to benefit the area it can lead to a
brain drain
if you make a local population more
skilled there is of course a danger that
many of them will leave to get the sorts
of jobs they want in other areas one way
to manage this risk of brain drain is to
make an area attractive to large
companies and employers
as Pittsburgh has done for some of the
world's biggest tech companies
Google it's an international brand that
calls Pittsburgh home Apple has its eye
on Pittsburgh Uber is totally pulling a
kit from Knight Rider and introducing
its self-driving cars to the streets of
Pittsburgh although the arrival of large
Prestige firms can price some residents
out it's generally good news for
struggling areas
the incoming Champion companies have the
heft in in many cases to not only hire
lots of local people but also to train
them and to influence the rest of the
regions uh labor market
from reskilling to
power and resources there are various
traditional ingredients for making
deprived areas more appetizing and
richer
but with no reliable catch-all approach
there's a growing hunger for new ideas
so how about luring new residents not
with a better job
but a better life
even when I told people we told them
we're like we're with the tallest MP
would be like where
welcome to Tulsa Oklahoma now home to
Jonathan and Haley who recently gave up
the bright lights of Houston Texas to
put down Roots here I honestly had never
been to Oklahoma or even heard of Tulsa
don't I think maybe through friends you
know there's an episode in friends where
Chandler has to go to Tulsa I think
that's the extent of it Tulsa Oklahoma
The Sooner State
that's you know that was the reaction we
get from it yeah and then we just found
just come visit us and see it you have
to
come and the secret to getting Jonathan
and Haley to migrate paying them the
city is now rebranding itself as a honey
pot for remote workers by offering them
perks to move here a privately funded
program called Tulsa remote Leo's new
residence with ten thousand dollars
worth of housing free workspaces and
other incentives the idea is to attract
people to the city like a hub attracts
entrepreneurs
let's go directly to creators right um
and and let's invite them to collaborate
we are now seven years uh into that
business and I am back home in Tulsa
because I love Tulsa
the hope is that the Tulsa remote
program will help kick-start a bigger
transformation
[Music]
folks that haven't come through toaster
mode they just themselves have come here
because they've started to hear you know
a buzz about something happening here
it's a bold new idea for poor areas to
make themselves richer and although the
program only started in 2018 Tulsa
remote says it's delivering bang for
buck the Tulsa remote program has made a
huge impact on the Tulsa economy we know
that for every dollar that we've spent
on that ten thousand dollar incentive
there's been a near 14 return on
investment to the city
other places have followed Tulsa's lead
in trying to change their fortunes by
enticing new inhabitants with cash
incentives over 80 cities in America now
offer similar schemes
but while it all sounds promising so far
the share of America's population who
have moved hasn't really changed since
the pandemic
my sense is that remote work though
important is a secondary form of work
and not a huge impact in most places
whatever the methods it's clear that
reinvigorating long neglected regions is
an enormous challenge for wealthy
countries in the current economic
climate
what's less apparent is the political
will to take on that challenge and some
say that's a big mistake
for me the dangers inherent in allowing
some places to fall behind isn't simply
that it's morally wrong but it is also a
waste of talent giving the same
opportunities to people from around the
country to achieve their full potential
will be good for the national economy as
a whole
America and Britain have been all too
aware of their Regional inequality
problems for a long time and they
continue to suffer the damaging
political consequences of not fixing
them
a backlash which may yet get worse
when people start to censor their pride
in places being undervalued they
themselves will start to react against
the institutional systems that we have
the Forgotten men and women
of the United States are forgotten no
more
and in a democracy that is potentially a
very dangerous thing to face
we need to invest now in the things that
will help bridge that gap between rich
and poor because as that gets worse
everybody pays
[Music]
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series click on the
other link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe